here in germany authorities have banned
travel from parts of neighboring austria
and
the czech republic the restrictions are
aimed at stopping the spread of highly
contagious variants of the coronavirus
which have been detected in several
border regions
the european union has criticized the
travel shutdown which is causing major
disruption for workers who commute
across the border
very little has got through this
checkpoint at the austrian-german border
since early sunday
many drivers trying to cross from the
austrian state of tyrol were told to
turn around
unless they work in a very limited
number of jobs classified as essential
it's much the same situation at the
german czech border
we have ensured that testing is
available for anyone who is eligible to
enter
but who doesn't have the results of a
covid 19 test
it's a difficult situation for commuters
some are even considering temporarily
moving to germany
and they say the changes to the rules
were badly communicated
we have no information we don't know a
thing
can we drive to work tomorrow will we
have to go into quarantine
i'm having a hard time i don't know if
my job's classified as essential or not
will they allow me to cross over i don't
know
we need the work it'll be hard without
this work
and if you have a family back home you
have to pay the bills there's no plan b
the czech commuters association says
bavarian officials did not inform their
czech counterparts about the new rules
we won't be forced to live in germany
we're not german citizens
we work there and we pay taxes there but
now the borders are closed again
just like they were 30 years ago
that was when europe was divided by the
iron curtain
and communist leaders in the east barred
their citizens from traveling to the
west
but today germany is worried about
highly contagious virus variants
traveling across its borders
we cannot allow these severe measures
these restrictions that have been
followed so well by the population here
in germany
to be for nothing the new variants could
seriously endanger that
and that's why we have border checks and
why we're turning people back
because i believe it's necessary
tens of thousands of commuters have now
been left wondering when they'll be able
to get to work
well the very latest let's take a look
at the situation at the german czech
border in the bavarian town of shending
it's a place where a lot of commuters
travel to work
in germany our correspondent barbara
basil is
there for us and joins us now
so barbara how's the border closure
affecting people
where you are
it's affecting people gravely because
they really as we just saw
don't know what to do can they come can
they not come but what we're seeing this
morning
of course is what was to be expected
long
lines of trucks here because after
sunday when trucks can drive
they all come out now and they're trying
to cross the border here
and it is a very slow process because
every single one of them
is being stopped and the drivers do have
to show a negative corona test
now for many drivers who just do this
cross-border traveling a lot
they have to go to a test center like
every other day it is
very slow it is cumbersome and they're
complaining
about it and saying it's a really very
difficult procedure
now this seems to have caught people on
the check side of the border off
guard barbara were they not properly
informed
no they weren't and that is one of the
big problems of course people are angry
people are
really dumbfounded they don't know
what's happening to them because this is
their livelihood i mean it's about 90
000 people who come across here every
day
we see on the other side there's still
some private cars lined up
but these people in there they're
presenting their work contract
and they don't know whether the police
will say yes you can go or you can't
and then from wednesday on it will be
even less
there will be even less people allowed
to come because then the rules will
become
even stricter and there will be a more
or less total shutdown here
except for some trucks rolling and so
this was badly communicated
the authorities on both sides of the
borders didn't talk to each other
and local people say it leaves a very
bad taste
because it sort of raises suspicion
against each other
and the hard-won unity and sort of
togetherness of people in this
big border region it could very easily
be lost
well talking about unity the eu tends to
frown upon
internal border closures has this
closure affecting the czech republic in
austria
been coordinated with the eu
absolutely not i mean it's been done
more or less by
by decision in munich by the federal
government in in bavaria and they've
just done it overnight and then just
said
we will close the borders basta finito
and they didn't even talk to anybody and
particularly they didn't talk to the
governments on the other side and say
how can we organize this how do we tell
people how this gun is going to work
and the question of course is can you
stop the virus
can you stop it at the borders if
commuters don't come over anymore
is that really what has caused the
spread of the british variant here
nobody knows that there is no proof for
it and so
many people think that this is
politically highly problematic
and also of course this region here will
be hit again
which has already been hearted by the
corona crisis we see many shuttered
shops and
places that are empty and they will just
have to take another economic hit
it is a very difficult decision it's
also very cold there as i can see
not fun for the people who have to sit
in their car for hours
uh correspondent barbara basil there in
shindig bavaria thank you so much
barbara
well here in the german capital our
political correspondent manuel shaz
is also on this story emmanuel what does
the
federal government here in berlin make
of the state of bavaria shutting its
borders
well there's been there hasn't been an
official reaction from angela merkel
herself this weekend but the situation
led to diplomatic tensions between
berlin and vienna the foreign minister
alexander schallenberg on the austrian
side
talked to his german counterpart heiko
mars yesterday
sunday and the german ambassador is also
expected
for talks by vienna now the house
minister yen span here in germany
defended the measures he said that
in light of the rapid spread of the
variants well these rules were
drastic but they were indeed the best
way to stabilize the infection rates in
german border regions
now the the federal government's the
federal government and the germany's 16
federal
states they've been at loggerheads
multiple times
in this pandemic the authority of berlin
has been
challenged on occasion has has germany's
federal system
proved a liability in addressing this
health emergency
well definitely the crisis revealed just
how much power the regions have in any
federal system
and revealed how much coordination
coordinated action was necessary and
time and again we see chancellor
we saw chancellor angela merkel wanting
stricter measures and she wasn't
followed by
the regional state premiers now germany
fares much better in terms of infections
than indeed
a month ago the seven days incidence
rate at a national level
is below 60 per hundred thousand
inhabitants
but the lockdown has still had to be
reconducted and time and again we saw
the difficulties of the
uh chancellor of the federal government
to agree on measures with the
original heads of states amanda thank
you very much
that was our correspondent manuel schatz
let's get more in this now we have dw
brussels bureau chief alexander fuhnaman
standing by for us hi alexandra
as we mentioned the european union did
not want border closures here so tell us
more about how brussels
is reacting to this today
well as you can imagine brussels has
condemned
germany's newest restrictions and also
urged the government and berlin to
facilitate
cross-borders cross-border movements of
commuters uh health commissioner curie
jackies
said in an interview that the fear of
coronavirus mutants
is understandable but that they are not
going to be stopped by close borders
and as we just heard from barbara only a
few weeks ago eu
leaders actually agreed that closing
borders
would be considered a last resort
measure
so brussels is not in use at the same
time we have to mention that
member states are allowed to temporarily
introduce border checks at their borders
if
there is a kind of threat or emergency
and of course
the spread of new coronavirus variants
can be
considered as a health emergency and we
know that the concerns over these new
mutations are very high alexandra so do
you think that we could see other member
states
follow this example from bavaria
well i really think that we cannot rule
that out that that can happen
because it's up to member states to
decide which
measures they consider appropriate and
necessary and of course it's also up to
them to decide whether
border controls have to be reintroduced
here in belgium for example the
government
decided to ban all non-essential trouble
however we also have to say that i i
think that member states are aware
that that could have a huge impact on
the
eu economy which relies on free movement
of workers and goods what about
commuters
and even tourists who are already
vaccinated are there any measures
in place to allow them to travel freely
not at the moment uh there is some
discussion here about uh vaccine
certificates there are some member
states like estonia for example who are
pushing ahead
with this idea and the eu commission
also wants to have a common approach
on this a topic at the moment however
such vaccine certificates are being
discussed as
uh medical documents and not documents
that would allow you to travel
or to go to a restaurant our brussels
bureau chief alexander fundament good to
talk to you
despite progress in vaccine rollouts
curfews and closures remain part of
daily life in many parts of europe
as we heard authorities fear the spread
of new varus virus variants
but there is one place where things seem
to have loosened up the spanish city of
madrid
and word has gotten around to tourists
meeting friends and enjoying drinks in
the sun
a rare pastime these days but possible
in madrid
and that's why the spanish capital has
become a refuge for young tourists from
france
it's so so depressing being in a country
that is
nothing's open it's it's gloomy all day
you have to be back there's a curfew
at six you can't even see your friends
or no cafes
there's no you know you can't sit down
with anyone you literally can't do
anything in in france in madrid
coronavirus restrictions are less strict
than in other parts of europe
a negative pcr test was enough for zita
di montil to come here
she didn't have to quarantine and also
brought a friend
i come here there is sun there is
friends
there is a terrace cafe it's amazing
it's a dream come true
a dream that theodore starp and iu colby
have also pursued
the students live in germany and are
spending a few days here
they planned the trip with friends
knowing that germany has advised its
population to avoid traveling to
high-risk countries
somehow you feel bad if you travel
because other people are self-isolating
and you're not supposed to travel at the
moment
but i don't think you can stay at home
for a whole year either
we want to see the world while we're in
the prime of our lives
during the day the students explore the
city in the evenings they stay at home
they say they feel safer keeping to
themselves
others feel differently madrid's police
sometimes have to break up illegal
parties held after a curfew
with participants ignoring current
contact restrictions
which is ideal for the spread of the
virus this party was organized by french
tourists
we've had to intervene on several
occasions all the participants were
foreigners who'd come to madrid for a
short time
two or three days they rent an apartment
and then they party
fines for these offences during the
pandemic start at 600 euros
spanish authorities are in contact with
their french
we counterparts internationally and
their mechanisms in place to pass on
information so the fines should reach
them
but you have to remember they're issued
by local authorities here
processing the fines is still a bit
bumpy when partygoers don't live in
spain
illegal parties also worried dr laura
sans
in the end they all contribute to more
infections
we already have to be very careful with
family members and in our everyday lives
unnecessary contact has to be avoided
the young people we met this afternoon
in madrid think both can work
being responsible and enjoying the
freedoms of life
we do all the pcr tests and everything
we wear the mask when we have to
we don't want to bother spanish people
you know we just want to
live again and in france we cannot do
that
for now madrid is one of the few cities
in europe that still allows some leeway
though that could change at any time
[Music]
okay let's look now at some of the
latest developments in the pandemic
a large israeli study shows the biotech
pfizer vaccine
is highly effective at preventing
serious illness
israel has vaccinated more of its
population than any other country
new daily cases in the u.s are averaging
below 100 000 for the first time in
months
but public health experts warn that
infections remain high and restrictions
should stay in place
the first vaccine doses have arrived in
australia and new zealand
quarantined hotel workers will be among
the first to get the shots
and england opens its quarantine hotels
today in a bid to keep out
new covet variants passengers from 33
so-called red list
countries will have to spend 14 days
under the new border restrictions
a new covet 19 vaccine candidate
developed by french drug maker sanofi
and u.s group translate bio will not be
ready this year
the news is another setback for sanofi
the company is already struggling with a
delay
in its other kobit 19 vaccine candidate
for which it has partnered with
britain's
glaxosmithkline the european commission
had ordered
up to 300 million vaccine doses of the
sanofi
gsk vaccine for the 27 member states
well for more let's cross over now to
our financial market correspondent to
chelsea delaney in frankfurt
chelsea the second time sanofi
failed in its attempt to produce an
effective covet 19 vaccine what's that
mean for the french pharma company
it's a major disappointment for sanofi
the company had invested a lot of money
and a lot of time into building
out these vaccine programs and both of
them just aren't really
bearing fruit at this moment so that's a
lot of wasted time that's a lot of
wasted money
and sanofi also had been really the the
front-runner at the beginning of the
vaccine race they had
received a lot of investment from
different governments it was really
seen as as one of the most promising
candidates and on now both
of its uh candidates are really falling
through but i'd say this is also a bit
of a blow to to
france in general you know the home of
louis pasteur the the founder of vaccine
technology it's been
really a big blow for them to not be
really on the map in terms of vaccines
right it must be quite disappointing and
it certainly is disappointing
for uh millions and millions of
europeans i mean europe
has invested a lot in developing
vaccines what's it mean for them
it's also a setback for europe as well
which has really gotten off to a very
slow start in terms of vaccines there's
massive shortages
of vaccines across the continent and the
sanofi
vaccines had been one of the the biggest
orders that the eu had placed 300
million uh doses that was one of its
biggest
uh biggest bets so that's certainly
delaying
some of the supply that the eu had been
hoping for but we also are
seeing sanofi step up and say okay we're
not going to be producing a vaccine
right now so let's produce other
vaccines so they've struck a deal with
for example pfizer and biontech here in
germany
to produce about 125 million vaccine
doses so
they are reassessing and re-distributing
some of their capacity to produce
vaccines for other companies
all right brilliant chelsea delaney
there in frankfurt thank you so much
you